hi i'm margot robbie and i play harley
quinn
hello i'm john cena i drink my own urine
and i play peacemaker
hi i'm joel kendall and i play rick flag
hi
i'm daniela melchior i don't have any
joke and i play ratcatcher 2.
and i'm james gunn and i am the writer
and director of the suicide squad
and we are all here to find out which
character in the suicide squad we
actually are
all right first things first if you were
a villain
what would be your redeeming quality
your ability to lead
your love for others your dedication to
the cause
your ability to take care of yourself
your understanding
of right and wrong or your loyalty to
your squad
for me i am picking my loyalty
to my squad because i'm pretty loyal to
my squad in real life
it's not all about you margot no i know
but this is all about me
my squad is me me
myself and my squad i'm gonna go with
the ability to do right and wrong
because uh right now i'm completely in
the wrong but it feels so right
i'm really loyal but i would say my
ability to take care of myself
not to run but to take care of myself
take a nap
maybe i'll take my ability to lead i'm
taking the same one i don't care
i can lead so i can also say the same
stupid thing that you said okay well in
that case i'll
say no don't you don't have to take a
different thing we could end up being
the same person you're supposed to be
real you guys are trying to kill the
veracity of this test it's upsetting
pick another iconic villain to join your
squad mr lannister from game of thrones
darth vader from star wars hannibal
lecter from silence of the lambs
vanilla familiar vanilli from killing
eve voldemort from harry potter
or regina vagina george from mean girl
never said i was a fanatic's ace either
i can go first
i would say villanelle because i just
love villanelle and killing eve
i'm gonna go with voldemort because he's
incredibly powerful and i'm a big harry
potter fan
i'm gonna go with hannibal lecter i mean
there's a lot of squad members that are
gonna die
and we don't want him to go to waste so
he'll be there and make a meal out of it
i would go for darth vader because i
would spend most of my time talking into
a stationary fan tending to do an
impression of darth vader
for me it's between darth vader and
voldemort because
they're the two most powerful the other
ones are all i mean they're nothing
so i want somebody powerful on my team
and i think probably voldemort's more
powerful right margot
i don't haven't really seen those i'm
gonna go with voldemort it's your big
moment of glory
which song is playing in the background
of your epic
fight sequence bohemian rhapsody by
queen apolly
by rosalia without me by eminem
hit me with your best shot by pat
benatar hold up by beyonce and
bad guy by billy eilish i'd say hit me
with your best shot
i'm gonna go with pat benatar i'm going
that one to hit me with your best shot
that's true
without me by eminem i'm the millennial
here so
i'm going with billy eilish bad guy
lily alicia i love you i wish i could be
your best friend
good tune y'all go without me by eminem
as well because i don't know a lot of
these others
i don't what's uh a palette
honorable mention would be bohemian
rhapsody i feel like it's still done
exactly
so done whatever what are you saying you
made the wrong choice john that's all
just saying favorite choice was
tasteless
for being the slowest kid in class so
that don't don't forget that as well
layers of the onion james layers of the
onion so
if you had rat catcher's ability to
control animals
which animal would you choose cats
goldfish squirrel squirrels
squirrels that's a hard one ants
pigeons orc peyotes and trying and
failing my whole life to try to find out
how to control cats i would say cats
me too i guess i'll take coyotes they're
the closest to dogs
i'm taking coyotes i have outside my
house every night there's like a rumble
between two coyote packs and it's
so loud and gnarly
that honestly if i could control them
and get them or just zip it so i can get
some sleep
how many are like how deep are their
packs it sounds like there's heaps it
sounds like there's like 15 in each gang
but i don't know i
haven't seen it with my own eyes they
really kick off every night i was gonna
say cats because i can't get my stupid
cat to
stop scratching up my furniture and it
would be nice to do that but i would
like to have somebody attacked by a
bunch of pigeons so i'm definitely going
i'm just imagining like you're getting
like a you know an argument with
somebody somewhere
and then all of a sudden could be a
really big huge guy
that would be amazing right all over
them that too
you could have their just their car just
like you looked at me funny i'm just
gonna have your porch covered in bird
poop
last but not least choose a not so super
power
the power to turn wine into water the
power to talk to animals but not
understand what they're saying to you
the power to teleport
three feet at a time the power to turn
invisible when no one is looking at you
the power to stop time for five seconds
at a time
the power to read minds with consent
i'm gonna stop time for five seconds at
a time because five seconds gets me
about three and a half orgasms
i'm also going with the five second
thing but for different reasons
fair listen the power to talk to animals
but not understand what they're saying
to you is fine because i would like to
be able to tell my animals
that want them to understand me that's a
really good superpower i feel like
i can talk to animals already and that
the power to read minds with consent you
know
do you have to ask permission like may i
read your mind
be scared to go on a date with you we
don't understand that that's what
consent is
consent is asking for permission what
i'm bloodsport i have harley queen i'm
rick flack i'm in joel right now
i'm you i'm in you wait where i'm holly
quinn
harley quinn you know i've been saying a
lot that she's my favorite actor i've
ever worked with in there you see it
right there
you can see why i'm harley quinn too
you guys it's a defining moment for me
i don't know how we're gonna follow that
you